a multi-billion dollar semiconductor
investment here in america if if this
book is passed and dr choi
ceo of samsung is also on the screen
thank you for being here samsung has
committed 17 billion dollars as largest
ever u.s investment to build a
semiconductor facility in texas which
you understand is going to create 2 000
good-paying jobs
other ceos here are making their way
their own investments in america
but
they need congress to pass the
bipartisan innovation bill
and one of the reasons well one of the
reasons we need to do that is because
there is a perhaps no production more
important than reclaiming america's
leadership and owning our future than uh
semiconductors
you know these semiconductors are the
size of a fingertip power about every
day almost everything in our everyday
life
smartphones the internet appliances
technologies we haven't invented yet
on our nation and
the semiconductor was invented here in
the united states of america and uh over
30 years ago america had 40 percent of
the global production of semiconductors
but since then something happened
american manufacturing the backbone of
our economy got hollowed out
companies moved jobs and production
overseas especially from the industrial
midwest
and the result today we barely produced
10 percent of these computer chips
despite
being a leader on
chip design and research
this puts us at the mercy of shortages
and supply chain bottlenecks but we have
an opportunity we have an opportunity to
reclaim the position of leadership i
think it's a bipartisan consensus
there's
there's an innovation bill that this
innovation bill has bipartisan support
in both house and senate now
it includes billions of dollars for new
uh incentives to produce semiconductors
here in america
and the bill
is not just about funding semiconductors
it includes an office at the department
of commerce that
will be tasked to monitoring and
strengthening critical supply chains
and and it expands programs that help
manufacturers across the country benefit
from our investments particularly small
manufacturers
it invests in r d the way we need to so
we can invent and make the technologies
of the future and and and industries
like biotechnology artificial
intelligence telecommunications
and others we can barely imagine today
and which we're going to build a
foundation for future jobs and
prosperity not just here but around the
world
so today i'm urging the house and the
senate to work out the differences
between the ver two versions of this
bill and get it to my desk as quickly as
you can
passing this bill will do four important
things
first we'll send a message to the world
that america is back in the game open
for investment commitment creating clean
energy
economy and competing to win in the 21st
century
second we're going to create jobs good
paying cutting ed jobs manufacturing
jobs many that don't require a four-year
college degree
third
making it in america is one of the ways
we can address our cost and supply chain
challenges
when we build a product when we build
products we need we don't have to wait
and we reduce
ship
shipping costs and we can get goods
moving faster
and fourthly we have we it will be a
it will mean that we aren't overly
reliant on other countries uh from risk
like wars and pandemics
and i saw during the pandemic that when
we needed the most we were a short
supply of mass gowns gloves ventilators
and other essential equipment
you should never be in that position
again the bottom line is this bipartisan
innovation bill
will allow us to stamp more products
made in america and it's going to
bolster our national security and
economic security it matters
so let's get it done
and now it's my honor to turn this over
to
the governors
and then we're going to hear from the
ceos and so governors
i'm sure you agree with the ohio senator
sherrod brown who said it's time to bury
the label rust belt
amen
like the industrial midwest today
you see something special that's
happening let me start with you governor
governor holcomb from indiana
yeah i thank you mr president and madam
secretary great to be back with you
again i i would just
echo or underscore the points at points
that you've made and certainly the
midwest is no longer the rust belt it is
a shining buckle on that belt and we are
just open for business but able to do
more
this
innovation bill ultimate bill that comes
together is a key part of our futures
it's a key part of the midwestern
microelectronics corridor if you will
that has everything to do with economic
development and national security for a
state like indiana you could probably
say this about a lot of midwestern
states but we're
heavy intensive in manufacturing number
one per capita for a state like indiana
five auto oems medical devices
the list just goes on and on and on and
i would i would just say that it's
two things one it's been said that speed
kills and in this sense slow speed kills
we need to get this done we need to get
it on your desk we need to get it signed
so that we can not just catch up with
the competition but lead
we know a little something about this in
indiana we got the indy 500 and we like
to go fast
a gallon of gas is down 14.
no so you know it's it's speed we got to
get there we're going to get there
yesterday and then also partnerships and
for
us and in the midwest we have those
talent pipelines madam secretary that
we've spent a lot of time talking about
purdue university one of the largest
engineering schools in the country top
ranked
roles holmen
number one undergraduate engineering
school so we've got a community college
system that has built the structure in
place
as well as naval
surface warfare center crane with the
dod and all the research that goes into
it so those the federal the private
sector and the state governments that
come together those partnerships uh are
in place right now so that we can
get it to your desk and get on with
business
i'll do anything to help if you kept me
to be able to drive a lead car in indy
[Laughter]
yeah i know i i i don't know man i'm
ready uh anyway um
uh
yeah well i'm really glad to be sitting
here next next to eric because uh in the
midwest you know we are proud of what we
do we work hard we solve problems we're
not afraid of uh digging in and this i
think this act that we're talking about
is a huge opportunity for our nation now
in places like michigan this is about
creating good paying jobs this is
about lowering costs for families this
is about our national security
i know my fellow governors on both sides
of the aisle support getting this to
your desk so that you can sign it and
make a reality
right now thousands of jobs up and down
the auto supply chain are at risk
because we are not making chips we don't
have access but i also know my friend
from whirlpool here also from michigan
it's gonna remind me it's not just the
auto industry right it's appliances as
well it is the smart phones as you said
mr president you know ship shortages
have impacted more than 575 000 american
jobs and in 2021 alone automakers in
north america lost production of an
estimated 2.2 million vehicles
equaling 3 000 days of work so these
shortages are driving up costs they're
jeopardizing families
and increasing this manufacturing here
at home
will reduce supply chain delays and
transportation as well as lowering the
cost of consumer electronics et cetera
et cetera
but we also saw during the pandemic that
american manufacturing is crucial to our
national security and when the whole
world comes to a halt because
swabs are manufactured in italy or n95
mass or manufactured in china
it is a national security issue so doing
this important advanced manufacturing
where we can stamp it made in america
and preferably made in michigan
is a good thing for our whole nation and
so that's why i think it's so important
that both sides of the aisle we are here
we are eager to
throw our support behind getting this
bill to your desk and recognize that
critical importance to the people of our
states and our nation so i'm i'm excited
to be here and eager to eager to jump in
wherever we can be helpful well you know
we're all friends you've heard me say
many times you know
out of something my dear mother god
bless her soul you should say out of
everything bad something good will
happen
you look hard enough for it and i think
we're in a position now we're in a real
inflection point in history not just in
america but across the world
there can be changes that are going to
whether no matter who's in charge
they're going to
create fundamental
fundamental changes taking place
geographically politically economically
technologically and
you know
one third of the inflation last year
was because of the cost of automobiles
and there was one reason another
computer chips
rising prices were you know that's
one-third of inflation
and so we can solve a lot of that i'd
like to uh with her with her permission
liz i'd like to go to you a little bit
speaking of whirlpool
um and uh
you announced an 80 million dollar
investment in the manufacturing plant in
ohio and oklahoma last year
i wish you're going to create about 250
jobs if i'm not mistaken
my question is that excuse me
why is domestic production of
semiconductors
important to whirlpool and
how will this bipartisan initiative it
passes and gets to my desk how how
that's going to affect you
i think i know the answer but i think
it's important for it to be heard from
you no i really mean it i think it's
important
look the one thing we've had as we
brought in ceos and and vps and others
uh
the last i don't know
a couple months right here in this four
is people go whoa this is real when they
hear from the companies what they want
to do and so i'd love to you to tell me
a little bit about how you see a
movement if you would well first of all
thank you mr president for inviting
whirlpool corporation to sit here today
at this table with all these
leaders so we're very very uh grateful
to be able to be here today
what i i would say is that the 80
million dollar investment in ohio and
oklahoma as you said you know that is us
supporting the united states
additionally we have made an investment
60 million dollar commitment in michigan
in our r d center
so
this is demonstrative of our commitment
to the united states we have nine
factories in the u.s we
sell 80 percent of the products that we
sell in the us are produced in the u.s
so it's definitely a commitment
here to the united states
we have been challenged with the supply
chain you know not being able to deliver
appliances to each of the consumers in
the u.s every day due to the
semiconductor issues
we
see the semiconductors as essential
component to our appliances they're
found in almost every one of our
appliances and they're absolutely
critical because they deliver the
technology that delights our consumers
whether it's cleaning your your laundry
or your dishes or cooking in the home or
using it to store your food and medicine
during these very challenging times so
semiconductors are absolutely essential
for us and certainly if we had all these
semiconductors as governor whitmer said
we'd be able to deliver the appliances
to all of our customers which we have
been challenged to do so
but we are absolutely uh committed to um
to to deliver to our consumers every day
do you think
your customers
and or even maybe
some of your employees who have been
around a long time
really appreciated how critical a
semiconductor was for them to make the
products and move them absolutely i
think everyone in inside our company and
i even think u.s consumers and world
leaders are very very familiar now with
semiconductors and how critical they are
to technology
research and development um upskilling
the workforce and stem education so
absolutely
well it's interesting that i i think
it's been a
unfortunately uh
you know a uh
it's been a reality that uh
the american public realizing that a
semiconductor
mattered a great deal whether or not
your washing machine functioned
or whether your cell phone functioned or
whether your automobile functioned uh
and uh
it's not that i think we it just took an
awful lot for granted we all did that
this is you know what
we can do this and not a problem
and the irony of i keep
reminding everybody of the irony is we
actually invented
the semiconductor we head to the moon so
we also i had no parenthetically we got
to be started investing a hell of a lot
more money in research and development
pure research and development
we used to do about two percent of our
gdp now we're down by one percent and uh
it's
anyway
but how want to get off on that to get
you going
um well thank you i i'd also like madam
president jennifer i you uh
at cummins uh you make some pretty big
engines
you manufacture uh
uh
and uh now
but now you're making battery electric
alternative fuel engines right that's
right and so
how
has the ship shortage affected chip
shortage affecting your company
and your customers and as we move toward
this energy future how can this
innovation act
and that's a shame you have to know all
about this legislation i mean you're
running a company but
um
how can this act help companies like
yours
remain globally competitive not just
here at home yeah well first mr
president thank you so much for the
opportunity to speak today and talk
about common support of both the
domestic innovation focus of this
legislation as well as funding
semiconductor manufacturing
cummins is a 100 year old company
headquartered in columbus indiana
we employ 25 000 employees in the united
states
and our employees are really focused on
driving innovation and producing power
solutions engines and also as you said
fuel cell and battery electric power
solutions for commercial and industrial
equipment and that those applications
serve some of the world's most demanding
and economically vital applications
uh i spent uh time prior to my current
role as chief technical officer so i saw
firsthand the need for innovation yeah
really the need the need for innovation
and the power of
government and private sectors coming
together to focus on innovation cummins
worked closely for a number of years
with department of energy a 21st century
truck program and in that program we
were able to advance technology and
improve fuel efficiency at trucks by 50
50 reduction in co2
uh and
much of that work has now made its way
into trucks that are on the road today
on our are benefiting society and i
think there's never been a more
important time than now to continue to
focus on
domestic and innovation when you
consider the environmental
and the technical challenges that we
face as a society so i think it's
critically important that we can come
together our industry and other
industries are transforming
how we will compete as we tackle these
challenges like climate change
is changing and so i think coming
together in a bipartisan way to talk
about how we drive and fuel innovation
in america is critical
to keep us at the leading edge with
these advanced technologies and new
solutions and bring high-tech and
manufacturing jobs
to the united states in the future so i
i think it's critically important
in my operational role i've been
spending a lot of time on this
semiconductor issue and it has been a
real issue for us for the last 18 months
our products do not run in most cases
without semiconductors they're critical
for emissions and safety control systems
and increasingly
we're utilizing them as our technology
advances and we have not been able to
get enough it has impacted our ability
to build and deliver
product to our customers
and it's an issue we continue to deal
with today so we strongly support the
chips act really focusing on
bringing domestic production to
semiconductors
here including some for our industry
which by the way are different than what
we use in our cell phone you know
because of the durability and harsh
environment our products operate in we
have specific chips that are critical
um to to continue to invest and fund
here in the us and so we look forward to
being a part of the conversation as we
move this important work forward well
you know the point you've all made is
that
as everything changes there's a
fundamental shift
to the reality that
we can't
we can't keep uh the combustion engine
the way it has been
it's even you see what's happening in
locomotives now you know and you see
what's happening
just across the board and uh
so and i think it presents an enormous
opportunity
enormous opportunity to improve the
health of the public overall number one
because we're moving in the direction
that we don't need
uh to propel most of what we have in the
future by
with regard to uh
oil products
and
you know uh
i was really pleased
and
gretchen and i talked about this a lot
when
we met with
the ceos of the automobile companies
particularly mary bear
and
she had
sued the state of california for having
a higher mileage standard than the
national standard
and
we had a long talk i didn't i'm not
taking credit for her changing her mind
but
she ended up calling me and saying that
uh we're gonna go uh we're dropped the
suit
and we're gonna go all electric we'll
get to halfway there within the next and
she said a date
and then ford jumped on and everybody
else and it's uh
because it is the future and it also
creates really a hell of a lot of jobs
too
good paying jobs and
increasing the technological
breakthroughs and uh
so any rate i think what you're doing
really matters and
i know we got a lot to talk about you
saw the team over here i'm not sure
about you know anybody but gina over
here on this side including me but uh
but all kidding aside we got a lot to do
and i think we can get a lot done
i really do
and uh
there's a little thing going on uh
uh in uh in europe right now and i'm
not gonna be able to stay with you the
whole time we're here
but uh
that's not gonna anyway diminish the
content of what we're discussing here
and um brian i'm told that uh
you're gonna run this show here yeah
well we'll give you a chance to uh
depart in the press as well and then
we'll continue
on here
[Music]
thank you yeah you guys thank you thank
you
thank you so much
yes
ah
you